[Music]
what's negotiable is contracts issues
and terms what's never negotiable is
your self-respect your self-esteem or
who you are how a narcissist treats you
is never negotiable what happens early
on in a relationship with a narcissist
they call it love buming but I really
prefer to call it conditioning because
they will start off by 50,000 text
messages a day and I love you and you're
amazing but then then after they've sort
of locked you in then they just stop and
then when you let that go then they of
go see I got away with disrespecting
that person and it was okay but that's
right at the beginning when you should
be like no it's not okay to disrespect
me right then and there the boundary
should be set on how to treat
you all right believe Nation I have a
very special guest with me here today on
this episode of tell me why I suck
Rebecca zung in the house known for
being able to handle narcissists
negotiate with uh some of the most
difficult people in the world stand up
to bullies and her new book called slay
the bully which is a USA Today
bestseller Rebecca welcome aboard thank
you thank you for having me on this show
I bring experts on who I'm curious about
and they basically tell me why I suck at
something and we turn it into a a
coaching show so I am your little guinea
pig uh for the next little bit I wanted
to start with this how do I know if I'm
a narcissist that's sort of a trick
question because narcissists don't ever
think that they're narcissists do I pass
the test then
automatically they're never
self-aware you know they they always
think that other people are
narcissists so if you're even asking the
a question does that mean that that
you're not or is it just some crazy mind
game that that's now the question that
narcissist really asked to knock
somebody off their guard if you're
asking am I a narcissist and you know
you really do want to know and you
really are concerned about other
people's feelings and you really are
concerned about how you
are impacting other people around you
and you want to make sure that other
people around you are taken care of and
you're worrying about their
feelings and I mean that's really the
true measure narcissist are not aware of
the collateral damage that they're
causing and the self-destruction that
they cause nor do they care I think I've
probably had the opposite problem most
of my life in that uh I'm more on
the uh to worrying about what other
people think to being afraid to do the
thing is there lessons that I could
Leverage from a narcissist to help me
but do it in a positive way I would say
if you take the
reverse which is there's always sort of
the the symbiotic relationship between
the narcissist and the
empath and
both people generally come
from are born out of traumatic
situations in their lives we've all had
a certain amount of trauma in our lives
and of course that's what makes humans
humans let me start with a narcissist I
think that might be easier in some
ways a narcissist has dealt with trauma
in their brain such that when we have
been exposed as
humans to fight or
flight our brains emit chemicals
hormones which is um cortisol and
adrenaline mostly
and what happens is with a narcissist is
that it causes a rusted development in
the lyic system part of the brain and so
uh while the prefrontal cortex part of
the brain continues to develop the limic
system part of the brain um doesn't
develop as fast let's just say and so
when they are presented as adults with
situations that may trigger
them such as it anything which usually
isn't as rational or reasonable as what
others might think it should be uh like
eye roll it could be a any perceived
slight then that lyic system part of the
brain will take over and there's a
response that's usually not in line with
what should be rational or
reasonable and that lyic system part of
their brain takes over and then they
are um now being run by that part of
their brain and many times um they don't
remember the way they've been acting
during that time and that's what's scary
because they will actually sometimes
even take themselves down to take you
down which is
why you can't negotiate with them or
Reason with them the same way you can
others that's the
narcissist now take the empath the
empath is the person who
says I can help you I will save
you I have enough love for both of
us I see you
narcissist
and I I see that you have been a victim
of trauma that horrible mom that you had
that terrible dad that alcoholic person
in your life that um terrible ex-wife
that you had I can love you back to
health
and the empath ends up having what I
call leaky
boundaries because they end up allowing
themselves to not
be um seen or heard
or they end up um their soul ends up
sort of being crushed in the process
they end
up the the life ends up sort of being
drained out of them as a result because
the narcissist just takes takes takes
and the empath just gives gives gives
and the empath's needs never get met in
that relationship I love it that's great
I'm I'm already taking some notes as we
go so uh I definitely connect more with
the with the empath side of things and
uh in in efforts I guess of not only not
being taken advantage of but more just
energy conservation and putting your
energy in the right spots because
dealing with ch challenging people is is
challenging and it's kind of only so
much you can take so I would love to
maybe dive into some strategies uh and
I've done a couple and you can let me
know if you think they're good or bad or
maybe you can give me some additional
ones for me to consider as I'm going
through so uh the first one I'm going to
give a
prop oh I've never done an an interview
with props before this picture makes me
very
uncomfortable so I helped somebody with
their YouTube channel which is which is
what I do you know I help a lot of
people with their YouTube channels and
uh as a as a gift he asked me for my
address so I gave it to him and then
this is what he shipped me and he
basically put my head on on a king's
body or some Royal looks like a king or
something and uh like this makes me very
uncomfortable like I would
never I would never uh uh commission one
of these I would never hang this up in
my office and so because it made me
uncomfortable I put it in the background
in my office and I see it every day uh
just as a I take it as a reminder to be
more bold and that uh it's it's uh you
know that's it's okay to be the king I
guess but is is this a good idea or am I
set myself up for torture every day what
do you think why are you saying that it
makes you look like a narcissist to do
that or no not not uh I don't worry so
much about what other people think when
they see it I mean it's in the
background of my videos I sometimes get
asked like what's that picture people
zoom in and they they're asking like why
is your face on a king's body uh I don't
care so much what the viewer might think
it's more for me that uh I have a
tendency one of the things that I've
taught myself is when something makes me
uncomfortable I try to lean into it uh
to get stronger yeah it's healthy to
actually see yourself a little bit more
in the the the next version of yourself
they they actually call that healthy
narcissism so is that moving like
helping if I'm an
empath I guess back to like my one of my
original questions is is there a way to
learn some of the things like a
narcissist would have this on their wall
all day long and like Giant and like the
first thing that you see when you walk
in maybe uh so are there things to
prevent being taken advantage of or to
prevent the Leaky boundaries I love that
term uh habits rituals routines uh you
know does something like this make sense
or am I just a a glutton for punishment
well but that's not really necessarily
what I kind of refer to as a boundary I
think of boundaries more in terms of
like your emotional self your soul self
more in terms of because that to me is
more like in in terms of confidence
in terms of you defining who you are as
your authentic self which is I think
also a good thing but to me it's more
like in terms of you know your emotional
self one of the things that I'll say
often
is what's negotiable is contracts issues
and terms what's never negotiable is
your self self-respect your self-esteem
or who you
are you know and so
how a narcissist treats you is never
negotiable how a narcissist speaks to
you is never negotiable and and so what
happens early on in a relationship with
a narcissist they call it love bombing
but I really prefer to call it
conditioning because they they will
start off by 50,000 text messages a day
and I love you and you're amazing
amazing and you're all this whatever but
then after they've sort of locked you in
then it's they just stop and then it's
why are you so needy and you know I
can't talk to you all the time and and
then when you let that
go then they they sort of go see I got
away with disrespecting that person and
it was okay but that's right at the
beginning when you should be like like
no it's not okay to disrespect me right
then and there the boundaries should be
should be set on how to treat
you
and that's where I say at you know when
you're ready to make some steps
on you know many people say where do I
start where do I start I always say step
one don't run step two make a u-turn
step three Break Free because it's those
kind of you're going to course correct
course correct because you got to make
these baby steps cuz you know being
being conditioned for so
long step one is you
know how are you going to be
treated by this person now and it's that
when you're an empath you just you're
like afraid that maybe they're going to
be mad at you or you're going to get
yelled at or there's going to be
backlash but what happens with us is
that you're really just delaying the
inevitable and it's it's not it never
gets better when you when you don't
bring things up and honestly it's better
to just rip the Band-Aid off and have
the conversation or do the thing
honestly it's just better to just do it
so one of the things that come to mind
is um
you know I love helping people with
their YouTube channels and at the
beginning when I started helping some of
the bigger names it's like oh my God
this person even wants to talk to me
that this is crazy like I this is
somebody who I looked up to or I was
watching their videos and now I'm here
helping them with what they're doing
what a uh what a gift and speaking to
Leaky boundaries I would just say yes to
everything and helping everybody and
then my calendar just got full with hey
can you help this person can you help my
friends then can I hop on another call
and can you help and uh I spent half my
time just hopping on calls for free
helping people and then I realized wow
I'm not getting work
done like this is fun but uh I'm not
getting work done and so I had to put up
uh not that they were necessarily
narcissists but I think one of the
challenges maybe of being an empath is
having all kinds of different leaky
boundaries uh in your words and so one
of the things I had to do was I save
Friday afternoons from my friends
or friends of friends and so I have a
couple spots every Friday afternoon and
that's my dedicated time to say okay
every Friday afternoon I've dedicated
three hours to helping people and that's
what I'm going to do and if it falls
outside of that then I'm not going to do
that because I have interviews to do and
videos to make and a team they on and
everything else is is that uh is that a
a good strategy is that what you mean by
overcoming leaky boundaries do you have
any either advice or suggestions based
off that scenario yeah I mean I think
that's a great idea because that way you
are controlling it any any way that you
can start to control so I have a you
know another way like that that I call
making a plan stand so under the a for
my anticipate I say anticipate what a
narcissist is going to do and be two
steps ahead of them anticipate that
they're going to try to bait you they're
going to try to trigger you right so how
can you start to control that you I say
making a plan stand so when you go to
um have a conversation with them meet
with them have an agenda when you know
what what's the scope of the
conversation is it going to be this
issue this conversation this make sure
they know about it ahead of time and
then have a time limit is it going to be
1 hour is it going to be two hours make
sure they know about it ahead of time
and then if they try to bring up
something from 10 years ago or something
from else you know then you can say no
this is what we're talking about and
then when it hits that time limit you
can
go I I love meeting with you this is my
favorite thing ever but
unfortunately gotta go yeah how do you
not get triggered I mean that they're
obviously picking on things that are
very sensitive your deepest insecurities
and they here they are picking on it
again is it just a matter of I know
they're going to do this and I know
they're going to say this and I know
it's going to hurt I'm just going to
breathe and Rebecca said uh to to deal
with it or like how do you not get
triggered in the moment when that's it
feels like an instinct to get triggered
so I say observe don't absorb so I try
to tell them just start to look at them
as if they're a toddler having a tantrum
on the floor so for those of us who have
children you know what toddlers look
like when they're having a tantrum on
the floor you don't get down there and
you don't take it personally you just
look at them and you go oh I can see
that you're upset
I can see that you're angry I it seems
like something has really upset you we
can have this conversation later when
you've calmed down and so you just you
know I always say like pretend like
you're reporting the news oh you know I
can see that you're angry and and just
pretend like you have like invisible
Teflon or invisible you know um boundary
that's come down around you and being
like Wonder Woman with your with your um
bracelets or super man with your chest
with the bullets coming off and you just
you know it just doesn't you know hit
you anymore because if you think about
the the lyic brain or whatever it has
nothing to do with you you know your
triggers are not my
responsibility so you know you can just
observe don't absorb so I give free
phrases for disarming narcissists that
disarm the nar.com and I give those out
quite a lot and I tell people go get
them use them
because it is helpful for people to just
have some things at the ready to just
say and um you know just oh thanks for
the feedback I'll keep that in mind or
whatever you know just have like a few
things at the ready to just spit out and
say because that way you don't feel like
you'll be so triggered one of the things
I I struggled with at the beginning of
giving feedback to people's channels and
advice is
some of the people I'm talking to are
very
narcissistic and uh want to blame
algorithm
way no not totally not not you but you
know they want to blame their team want
to blame the YouTube algorithm want to
blame everything else and and uh I need
to navigate to say oh like it it's
you what advice would you give people
who uh are dealing with clients or
business connections maybe they it's not
their spouse or they're in a
relationship but it's a business
relationship that they want to navigate
uh where they have to deal with somebody
who's a narcissist yeah I call it
projection and deflection lying and
denying usually I say try to find
different
clients different you know because if
people aren't going to accept your
feedback then you know I mean back when
I was practicing law and I would have
clients like that I would be like
um where should I send your
file let me know where to forward it
because if you're not going to accept my
advice then we cannot have a working
relationship you know and then usually
at that point they would go oh no no no
I'll I'll listen you know because you
always have the best leverage when you
don't have to have the relationship
right um and so I would to say in those
situations
that you know you're there to advise
them and you're the expert and remember
your power in this you're you're the
authority you know what you're doing and
stand in that power and so if they don't
want
to listen to
you then it's not a a workable
relationship anymore
because that's the type of person and I
don't know who it is that you're talking
about at all so just to disclose anybody
who's listening I have no idea who
you're talking about but that's the type
of person who when things don't go their
way they're going to come back to you
and
say your it's your fault that things
aren't going well with my Channel or
whatever because um you know I paid you
and things aren't going well and blah
blah blah even though they blamed
somebody else when you tried to tell
them what was happening you know in
talking about slaying the
bully is there a case to fight back and
and so far everything we've talked about
has kind of been either get get them out
of your life have the conversation have
the plan uh be the comman and like work
an exit out is is is there a a case to
actually then like beat up the bully or
is that not advisable or just you're
you're you're playing with uh gunpowder
well you do in the sense that when I
teach people how to negotiate with them
I teach people how to do it through
threatening a source of Supply which is
their what I call Diamond level Supply
which is how they look to the world that
is more important for them to keep than
the
supply that they get from manipulating
you which is what I call Coal level
Supply and that's the leverage that's
how you get them out of your life
because otherwise you're never going to
get them out of your life and I mean the
problem is because of the lack of
self-awareness that they have they have
or don't have um you're not going to get
them to change I mean it's hard enough
to get other people people to change in
life in general I mean if you're in a
marriage or whatever people know I mean
I've been married for 23 years so I mean
and I will say that that's one of my
most significant
accomplishments you know I mean marriage
is hard you know relationships are hard
when you're not married to a narcissist
you know but being in a relationship
with a narcissist is a person who's not
self-aware who's not interested in
let's have a heartfelt conversation
about how we can work together jointly
or whatever I mean so when that's the
case you're never going to get anywhere
you're not with a person who's going to
be interested in feedback at all you're
never going to get your needs met ever
so I asked because I'm you know I'm I'm
having fun I guess I I see these as
challenges um and again I walk I like to
walk into uh the Challen all as opposed
to maybe walking away I guess there's
definitely times where you need to walk
away but um in I've gotten better at
navigating some of these difficult
conversations I would much rather
everybody be nice and get along and be
open and that's great um me too that's
not how it works a lot of
times and so what I found was like some
people learn only through intense debate
and
fighting so I remember um and he's a
friend um and otherwise when you're not
talking about business he's easy and
great to deal with but as soon as you
get the business and super successful
guy he will railroad people and if you
don't fight back it means you're wrong
which is not necessarily true it just
means you're not fighting back and so I
remember I was talking to somebody on
his team about a strategy he overheard
part of it without full contact text and
said that's the worst effing idea I've
ever heard right and immediately it's
like you know shrink up he's like wow
you know I don't swear I don't I don't
like yell at people even if I didn't
like the idea it would it's very
uncomfortable for me to be in that kind
of position um but okay like the fact
that I'm uncomfortable just like you
know the the picture that makes you
uncomfortable is like okay I'm going to
I'm going to dive in and see how to do
this and uh it's really just the only
way that he learns is by standing
toe-to-toe with him and so I had to then
stand up and say listen you've known me
for however X number of years I've never
given you something that doesn't work
don't just come in here and assume that
my strategy is a effing terrible idea
when you haven't even heard it and you
you come across and take a little you
know Whisper of a conversation and now
you're making a judgment call that's
absolutely wrong right and then like
then he respects you so like he only
respects the fight and every time I go
to meet him about what he's doing like
I'm I'm prepared for the fight and the
way that I deal with it is this isn't a
personal he's not attacking me it's not
a uh he's against Evan this is how he
operates and so when I'm stepping into
the room with him I need to either not
go into the room at all to you know kind
of your point like find different
clients or find different people to be
around or adjust how I'm showing up
because if I'm not ready to fight he
doesn't take the advice um where other
people if you coming in with a fight
like they don't want to deal with you at
all so I'm find myself being more of a
chameleon of adapting to the person I'm
talking to as opposed to just having the
one rot that doesn't sound necessarily
maybe like a narcissist that might just
be a way of being and a familiarity
thing I mean because that sounds like a
person who is taking feedback and maybe
does care about people I mean a
narcissist remember is a person who has
no empathy I mean you have to remember
it's a person who has the most shame the
most pain pain and so you almost have to
picture a person who has like a really
bad toothache and and when you have a
really bad tooth AE you can't see or
feel anything about anybody else because
you're just all you can see is yourself
and so you know I I just I think you
have to kind of separate out what a
narcissist is from a person who might
have different personality quirks or or
or you know maybe that's just the way
that person interacts with people their
way of being what's familiar to that
person but that doesn't necessarily make
that person a narcissist and also
remember narcissism is a spectrum
there's a at the end of the spectrum is
the the actual disorder and then you
know as you kind of get closer and
closer to this end of the spectrum is
the um is
the maybe more and more narcissistic
traits or Tendencies I mean we all kind
of have some narcissistic traits and
tendencies right I mean to a certain
degree that's an interesting point I
think I think the word narcissist is
thrown around a lot especially on social
media people just labeling others as
narcissists without even really know
what it what it is or much about the
person do do you know what percentage of
people are actually narcissists is there
there's research on this yes so it's
something like 7% are actually
narcissistic personality disorder but
then if you throw in other types of
disorders that lack
empathy that like um I think antisocial
personality disorders and other types of
disorders that lack empathy then it's
like up to 15% of the population lacks
empathy and you know what I say is if
you if each one of those people
emotionally abuses just three people in
their lifetimes then that's something
like 158 million Americans and 3.4
billion people in the world so it's like
pretty much all of us have had uh some
kind of brush with somebody like that
for sure do you think about situational
narcissists I mean I'm sure when we're
stressed and we haven't slept and we're
in Crazy pressure situations and
somebody in our family is dying and like
we're not showing up as our best self
right yes you me anybody yes and that's
something that
they talk about in in my research you
know they say if you feel sick if you're
not feeling well you know all of that
makes you because it is a spectrum right
so it makes you further down on the
Spectrum you feel more like you know I
want it to be more all about me right
now yeah for sure okay and so if you had
to if we go back to like a my audience
is more mostly entrepreneurs if you go
back to like a business context and uh
let's say you had to deal with a
narcissist client for 6 months you know
like you're trying to unwind it you're
trying to get out of it as soon as
possible but you still have this
contract that you're legally obliged to
how how do we best navigate those six
months so we don't end up uh in our own
version of hell yes so I have something
I call fluff or favor vomit
later so you know you kind of fluff up
their ego to get a little something that
you know get they get a little something
they want you get a little something you
want so you know they basically it's
exactly what it kind of sounds like you
narcissists love when you fluff up their
ego you fluff up their ego like you
fluff up a pillow and then you know you
get a little something that you want in
return so you know oh you know you're so
good at this so you know then you get a
little something that you want in return
so I I mean I would just say just
remember to what I call kind of
ethically manipulating the manipulator
hey you know you're really great when
you are like this so let's remember to
be you know blah blah blah it's a little
bit of if you know what neurolinguistic
programming is um that's you know um one
of the best videos I and I talked about
this actually in my previous book
negotiate like you matter of all
time everybody should watch this uh on
this subject matter it it wasn't meant
to be this but one of the best
instructional videos on NLP is when Mr
Rogers went to go ask for something like
$20
million from Congress in like
1969 and it's it's only like a six
minute video or something it's on
YouTube and he goes
and Senator
pastori is says all right Rogers you got
the floor and he's known as like this
crusty Senator and he he he like I hate
kids and I hate this guy and this dweeby
dude from this Pittsburgh station this
closed circuit Pittsburgh station who is
asking for all this money who the heck
is this guy and he comes in he's like oh
you know I I I love children as I know
you do and you know she's using NLP
right and I'm I'm sure that you will
enjoy it and all the way that he is
speaking to him by the end of it he's
like oh I can't wait to watch it and oh
I everybody's going to love this and the
guy is like putty in his hands and you
got the money uh and absolutely and it
it's it's so transformative to watch
this this video so I highly
recommend everybody go check it out for
NP cool I never heard that story so uh
I'll check it out and see what it's
about that sounds cool yeah I like it
now if we go to hiring right I've got 42
people on my team we're we're constantly
expanding uh how do we make sure that
we're not bringing on narcissists
especially as we add layers now so like
I'm not direct managing everybody and if
you say that at the beginning of
relationship the narcissist is all great
and flower and doing all these amazing
things how do you spot it earlier so you
don't have a train wreck on your hand
six months later such a great question
narcissists will often times first of
all they will say their last employer
was they usually badmouth their last
employer just the same as they
badmouth you know their exes or whatever
it's always like they're the victim of
something so so that's definitely a red
flag okay and then they will come off
super Charming very
charismatic you know it's almost too
good to be
true and they
will you know it's almost like
they're sort of selling you on something
it's it's you know you can almost tell
that there's something off because
they're selling you on something their
last employer was awful they were a
victim of it and they
will talk about themselves quite a lot
in the interview it's all about them and
I did this and I did that and I I
created all the systems in the last
thing and I was the guy and I was or I
was the person who made it all happen
and you know know it was but then they
let me go and or whatever it was that
you
know it was just but then I got the bad
the shaft or the it wasn't aair
something happened and so I mean I would
look for those kinds of red flags like
that how good is your narcissism radar
now I guess and and how quickly can
somebody develop their own radar I think
it's pretty good now and I I mean
unfortunately because I had a
narcissistic business partner I had and
it was just a few years ago
I it you know was pretty awful for me
and this is after I had you know a
pretty big law
practice and you know I it was what I
have discovered about myself is is that
while I'm really really good at
advocating on behalf of other people and
I know that I'm very good at that it
also makes me a very very good friend
people I'm a very loyal friend and I
have a lot of really wonderful friends
because of that I was not was not very
good when it came to having a business
partner because I also had very leaky
boundaries oh sure I'll do everything
for the business and let you take credit
for it all
you know so that was
not something that I would be willing to
do again and so I it really was not a
good situation for me and now I think
I'm pretty very I know that I'm very
good at it and I will not I now defend
my light with my life is what I say I
like that I like that defend your light
with your life that's great yes um to
your point about the you know vomit or
fluff them up and vomit later what's the
exact wording fluff for favor vomit
later it just made me think of you know
a lot of times when I'm dealing with
some of these people again talking about
their
channels uh one of the things that I
found let me push them was giving them a
ton of compliments for what they're
actually good at and they take pride in
so ex if I just went in and attacked
them on their Channel like okay this
sucks you got to fix this like then they
got really defensive because they
interpret it as a personal attack that
they suck at something but if I led with
oh you're you're such a great speaker or
you're a great whatever but it wouldn't
be vomit later because I'd have to find
something that I could genuinely connect
to of like what I admire about this
person if they know that I hold them in
high esteem now all of a sudden the
YouTube channel is not the thing that
they have their ego tied to so if I say
that their intro sucks or their thumb
nail is not very good like they're not
they don't care about their thumbnail
they're focused on what they care about
which is being you know great leader or
speaker or whatever else and so I found
that that allows me to get way deeper
way faster push them even harder if you
acknowledge some of the things that
they're great at before diving into the
feedback exactly exactly so that's the
point of it right fluffer favor vment
later but just agulation they want lots
of agulation you know you're kind of
like the uh the champion of the of the
empath right you're like hey if you're
the empath or you're the one being a
victim here here's how you stand up and
take control of your life and you don't
have to live like this anymore it's the
world doesn't belong to the narcissist
it can belong to the impath if you
follow these strategies um which I love
because I connect with that me too where
do empaths
struggle in leadership in building a
business in you know again I've got 42
people if I want to scale to 4,200
people what are the things that um I
need to be aware of uh as an empath that
might hold me back as opposed to we're
talking about all the pros of me being
an empath but what are the cons that I
need to be aware of as I grow my
business and bring on more people well I
think
it's
mostly I I want to be a nice person but
I also want to be assertive and I want
to stand in my power and I want to tell
this person that I don't like what
they're doing and I want to but I want
to be kind but I don't want to be taken
advantage of it's it's sort of like that
balance all the time of you know I want
to stand in my authentic power and I
want to grow as a human being but I'm
afraid that people aren't going to like
me if I if I do that there's always sort
of that thing that the I think that the
empath struggles with and I think that
that that's where I'm I'm constantly
trying to tell teach empaths
to to just stand in your own power
period and and you know stop stop trying
to make not your people your people and
that your people are going to be your
people and not everybody is your people
and you know focus on yourself and and
and your people will gather with you the
the people that are worth having as your
people is there a way to develop skill
set
to expand who your people could be well
I think that as you raise your
vibrational energy and your you raise
your vibrational level that and and you
put yourselves
in amazing situations like you know
where you're you're you're networking
and you're
you're you're uh focusing on personal
growth that you will
naturally attract the best people around
you as you as you have found right as
you know
that it'll naturally come because you're
standing in your authentic
power
everybody will naturally vibrate toward
you because authentic power is something
that is uh very magnetic yeah honestly
like I think I've been fortunate there's
a lot of you know in my industry a lot
of uh jealousy and backstabbing and
conflicts and uh pretend to be nice in
public and then like hate each other
behind the scenes and I'm I'm just kind
of the friendly Canadian who is nice to
everybody well but there there is that
you know there is that but you know I
remember my business coach who I've had
for 15 years you know when I first
started on YouTube and I would start to
see the hater remarks I was like oh my
God and and she was she said to me oh
when I she she first started coming up
and she was like oh uh Kelly you know
somebody had said to her oh you're not
big enough to have haters yet meaning
like the converse is like when you get
big enough you're going to have haters
right it's just kind of part of the game
part of the deal and you know if you
just sort of wrap your head around the
fact like oh 25% of the people are going
to hate you and 25% of the people are
going to love you and 50% of the people
are going to be in between or whatever
and just focus on the people who love
you and that's just the way it goes and
and you just
kind of close your mind to it and I
don't know I
just I think that that's just sort of
how you have to be you know I honestly
really struggled in my journey up
because I I didn't connect to how other
people had done it and you know my agent
uh is in New York and has the same
represents a lot of the people in our
industry and um he was always pushing
like you got to be famous like we got to
make you famous like but I don't want to
be famous I don't care about being
famous Steve uh and you got to be
controversial you got to tell me like
tell me what you think about Trump and
tell me what you think about whatever
was in the news it's like but I don't
want to talk like I don't know I'm not a
I see both sides too easily like I'm not
controversial enough um and so it was it
was a it was a fight for a good number
of years in um trying to figure out like
how do I stand and a lot of the we don't
get very many negative comments on the
video at all right like whatever
percentage it's it's really skewed
towards positivity like it's 99%
positive comments mostly because the the
content is all positive right it's we're
never attacking anybody it's always
positive which is a slower way to grow
versus if I did you know the doing the
top 10 rules of uh Kanye West versus
saying the top 10 stupidest things Kanye
has ever said uh you know the stupid one
would would get way more views than
rules for Success you know uh but I just
don't feel good like I would I would
have stopped making videos probably by
now if it was putting out negativity in
the system instead of positivity so it's
a much slower tortoise wins the long
race I guess kind of path instead of the
the faster way and it took a lot of I
don't even know what I held on to like
why I didn't it just didn't feel right
to take that advice and I really
struggle to come up with uh go out and
attack whoever is in the news and tell
tell us why that person's an idiot yeah
I mean I I was kind of joking about the
percentages because I don't even know
what my percentages are but I mean I
I've shied away from that too especially
with narcissism I could very easily
start into the whole politics thing but
I am not going there at all because I'm
about helping people find authentic
power and I feel like if I started down
that path it would totally just
changed my brand completely and that is
just not what I want to do at all and so
I'm I'm with you on that completely I
mean even this show is called tell me
why I
suck where it's like hey you know punch
at me this is great I love it it's a
chance to to learn and grow and bring on
Experts to you know help me improve and
get better as opposed to let's pick on
somebody the news and say why they suck
you know um okay so back back to the
hiring
thing so I love the I love the comments
you had about you know everything they
take credit for everything that went
well and they're it's all i i i i
instead of talking about a team and
they're they're bashing their boss or
whoever else on the team if they're a
narcissist and that come on at the
beginning are they also so you mentioned
kind of on the relationship side
everything is great and they're texting
you and telling you you know they love
you and how special you are and all that
stuff at the beginning of a of a
placement like if you're hiring somebody
at the beginning are they overd
delivering are they like doing the work
are they doing what they're supposed to
be doing and more like does that turn
into actual actions or is it just talk
well usually right at the beginning once
you've hired them you can see right away
that there's a problem almost
immediately there's a problem they're
not getting along with the co-workers
they are demanding that you know there's
a air conditioner by them or there's a
heater there's a problem there the
There's issues with all kinds of issues
almost immediately right away I mean
I've seen it myself because you know I
used to have a big law firm and I had a
lot of employees like in an actual brick
and mortar place and I used to see these
kinds of problems almost immediately
right away so one of the things that
we've done in our hiring and like this
is might be I'm I've been channeling
Rebecca Vibes the whole time I maybe
wish I had met you you know 20 years ago
to make my path a lot faster but in our
hiring process we don't even do
interviews we don't ever get on a zoom
and talk to people we have a just a
basic level of like did you fill out the
form prop like the the job application
properly some kind of um skill testing
question like tell us how many
subscribers we have on our YouTube
channel and if they don't tell us that
in the first line of their application
we don't even look at it because a lot
of people like that just eliminates 80%
most people just apply app to a job and
never do any research you just send
their cover letter and resume in and now
you're stuck for 5 minutes to read each
one where they spent 5 Seconds to do it
but after that as soon they they filled
out the uh the application properly uh
we just give them a test project like we
hire them we hire them for five hours
paid on something that we think should
take two and then we just see did they
do the work that they ask questions and
how fun was it to work with them
and that's the final Arbiter is like at
the end okay did they did they do the
work did they do it in two hours did
they do it in five hours uh so are they
you know slow and ACC competent or are
they ripping you off or are they you
know a good honest person and was it fun
working with them and that's always the
final call is okay their output might be
good but did they ask a million
questions were they were they slow did
they bother you for whatever reason um
and now my wife Nina does most of the
hiring and if you don't pass the need a
Vibe check you don't get in that sounds
like a good smell test to me good vibe
test to me because I think I think a lot
of times in an interview what what
you're hiring for is not what they're
being interviewed for so like if you're
a salesperson then a job interview makes
sense you're selling yourself let me see
how well you can sell yourself but if
you're a video editor how well you do on
a job interview is not correlated to
your work at all and so I'd rather work
with them on a video and say hey here's
my video spend five hours up to five
hours working to make it better and
communicate with me in the process so
we're basically doing a little mini
sample and we dive into doing a little
project together I guess it's more
upfront work to do it with you hire 20
people you got to do these little mini
projects with everybody but you find out
faster compared to going through a long
job interview process and then you
figure out oh this is the wrong person
and then you got to start the whole
thing all over again so but do you do
any sort of like culture index or disc
or anything like that we do zero but but
again like maybe that's why I suck I
haven't found the one that works so
we've we've given uh Myers Briggs and
we've
given uh Colby and we've given a few to
the people who've been with me the
longest and said okay guys fill this out
no this like there's no wrong answer
we're not this is not part of your
performance or anything I'm just curious
to see like who we've got on the team
and there was no pattern that we can say
okay we need to hire you know Advocates
or Defenders or what I forget what all
the terms are oh yeah I'm in a um a u a
mastermind women's Mastermind with Tracy
Holland and Danielle KY and um it was
co-founded by Daniel KY who I think you
know we did this the the last intensive
that we were out at in September we did
a culture index and that was
absolutely mindblowing that was
literally the most mind-blowing of all
the personality tests I've ever done I
had never heard of it before but that
guy was like a Seer he was like oh my
gosh it was different than the disc or
the or the Myers Briggs but that guy
could literally like he was like a black
magic person or something so from I'm
actually using that from now on for my
team okay and there's like a there's a
profile they fell out or a series of
questions or yes yeah yeah okay yeah
really yeah yeah so it's allly just
because we haven't found the right one I
love I love processes it's just been
that they do the work that they do it on
time and did we like working with them
and if they did good work on time time
and we like working with them you're
hired um and we've had people now with
us for like a decade even though on
paper like why did you hire this person
I don't know I didn't look at their
resume they they did great work we like
working with them and they did it on
time so and they're still here but that
may be it's you know that's one of those
things that maybe gets you to 42 people
but not 4200 people exactly exactly well
yeah I mean and that's why I'm actually
going to start using this myself because
TR Holland who was one of the who's the
founder of this group she actually just
sold her company hatch Beauty to you
know the same company that owns massive
huge Brands and she's she said I'm a bad
picker so she's been using this guy for
years for um to build her entire company
and I I said okay that's what I'm doing
from now on to because I don't think I'm
a great picker
either when it comes to being able to
you know choose the exact people and the
exact positions in my companies you know
so I mean building a digital company
where everybody sits in different places
around the country is so different than
a law firm where you know people were
actually all under the same roof it's so
different any other advice for you know
I guess a lot of times when you're at
least from the content I've seen you
know you're dealing with a power Dynamic
where either you're or the narcissist or
the bully is higher than
you is there any other advice for when
they're below you on the food chain like
you're the entrepreneur and you have
somebody else working for you who's a
narcissist or a bully whether it's
whether it's finding out who they are
faster screening them out or anything
things we haven't talked about when when
the power Dynamic is kind of Switched
where you're the leader uh and you have
the power in the situation yes and I can
tell you that from experience having you
know don't keep them and think that
you're going to solve the situation and
make it better because what happens is
you don't realize the impact that that
person is having on the rest of the team
and it really can lower morale and and
and hurt not just it's not just the cost
of letting that person go and now you
have to
hire somebody else it's the impact of
the morale on the rest of the team and
and how it can hurt it's the ripple
effect it can be much more pervasive
than what you think and and as an
employer or a boss sometime sometimes
you're just not aware of what's
happening so I would just
be you know really really careful about
keeping that person on too long what I
would do is is is is
probably take care of it sooner rather
than later do you have any advice when
it's a a big transition um so in my
example I acquired a
business maybe eight years ago nine
years ago and in acquiring the business
I also acquired their team and those
were not people that I picked on the
team and now I want to be a good boss
and I want to get to know team and like
here we are guys are building this and
and being an empath what I found was
all of their problems I would feel and
take on and then I went home and I was
like not sleeping super stressed out
getting all like emotional just
constantly thinking about all these new
people and wanting to make it work where
in my business has always been one
person hired at a time where now I have
30 people that I need to integrate in uh
and I just I was overwhelmed I was a
wreck for a couple months um so if I
after that I'm like I'm not acquiring
another business again so is there uh
that maybe you know limited thinking or
small thinking how would I do that
better if I'm going to acquire another
company and I'm bringing on 30 people
how do I manage that better I don't know
how long it was
before you you H you know when the
acquisition time was that you might have
had a chance to sort of sit down with
each employee and figure out maybe even
before the clo of the company and try
to sort of sketch out where everybody
was and have conversations with people
ahead of time so that you're not like
trying
to close and then figure it out you know
if if there were any if there were any
opportunity prior to that to to make it
a little bit smoother of a
transition I would have maybe that that
would be the only thing that I could
think of with that and and again with
the culture index you what this guy does
is actually take each person's profile
and then fit each person exactly where
they are meant to be but if there were
any opportunity to have conversations
with people ahead of time and then make
a smoother transition find out get
feedback where do you want to know what
is it that you expect from this
transition what is it that you're is
your long-term plan you know that kind
of thing ahead of time I think because
everybody's always afraid when there's
going to be a merger or an acquisition
you know what what's going to happen
what's going to happen with my job what
is it you know what's happening with me
and taking time to listen to them I
think ahead of time maybe could help to
assuage some of their concerns and make
them feel heard everybody wants to feel
seen her and know that they matter and
so I think that might have helped in in
some way I thought I did a good job with
that but looking backwards I probably
could have done a way better job with
that especially with h your your wise
counsel and uh at the time I justed to
tell myself I I can't care about this
person's like meritable problems right
now like the pro they're having a
problem in their relationship and like
I'm feeling bad for them I'm taking on
not just their business concerns but all
of their life concerns and like 30 new
people all at once and it just was
intense I'll keep that in mind if I
decide to go back into that
um last question you got your book slay
the bully USA Today bestseller what
message from that book uh connects most
to what we've been talking about
today I always say people will think
what you tell them to
think and that is that when you walk
into a room or even when you show up on
a zoom or
whenever you appear wherever you are
your essence your power your energy
wherever it is it's not just the words
coming out of your mouth it's your body
language it's it's how you show up for
yourself it's it's it's every cell of
your body and so once you decide who you
are people will think what you tell them
to think and I often tell this story
about how I had been a lawyer for eight
years and then I had been a financial
adviser and stock broker at Morgan
Stanley for two and then I went back to
being and starting my law practice and I
was so afraid people were going to think
I was such a flake and my I told my
business coach that and she said people
will think what you tell them to think
she said you can tell them to think that
you're a flake or you can tell them to
think that you are more qualified than
any other lawyer because you're the only
lawyer in town now that has a financial
background which story would you like to
to tell and I said oh maybe I'll tell
that
story she said people will think what
you tell them to think so I decided to
people to think that I was the only
lawyer in town that had a financial
background and so I stood in that power
and within a couple of years I had one
of the top family law practices in
Florida you know I represented
billionaires and celebrities but you
know people will think what you tell
them to think so so stand in your power
you and you alone create your value you
define
it whether it's a narcissist or not that
is the true value of that the true
essence of the why the U in my sleigh
method and no narcissist will have any
power over you or any any any power over
anyone if you know who you are I love it
well the woman is Rebecca Zang the book
is slay the bully we'll link it up in
the description below Rebecca thanks for
coming on and telling me why I suck
thank you which you
don't to see my one-on-one with Mel
Robbins check out the video right there
next to me I think you'll love it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there I hate you Evan I hope you lose
Evan I hope your business goes bankrupt
Evan Evan you're a terrible person I
spent the first 40 some years of my life
trying to be somebody else